My phone..
..stopped..
Why,??
you're the most irrelevant person I know-
Listen......carefully..
I'm speaking code.
my wife and I...
...were on a lovely Vacation...
I had an Important Meeting
*snores*
Where is your Sense of Adventure?
so she went out to see the local wildlife....
..Wow..
What is wrong with you?!
and met up with some....
...fans...
you...are Turk Henry's wife...
And now they want to meet me..
This Could Be Straight Forward Kidnapping
Or something more sinister like..
Terrorists..
Terrorists??
Terrorists..??!!
We heard some Chatter..
over The Homeland...NSA...meta Data Harvesting machines Up in outer Space..
I have had to  make the choise...
..between starving..
..and Freedom
When I was Modeling I had to skip me on all the time too....
I'm getting my wife back.
and I'll bring you the head in a bag..
I don't want her head in a bag...
..where would i put it??
The fridge.
*aaaahh*
That's what I have to deal With on a Day-To-day basis
you